cuando observamos toda la diversidad
viva a nuestro alrededor
una pregunta natural es que están
relacionadas están las diferentes
especies entre sí y si lo ponemos en un
contexto evolutivo el parentesco entre
ellas debería estar ligado a qué tan
reciente es el ancestro común entre dos
especies y lo que vamos a tratar de
hacer en este vídeo es construir un
árbol para mostrar cómo diferentes
especies evolucionaron a partir de
ancestros comunes y vamos a hacerlo
basándonos en algunos rasgos visibles
pero esta va a ser una enorme
simplificación porque solo voy a
trabajar con cinco especies y cinco
rasgos muy simples pero como veremos o
como hablaremos en vídeos futuros esto
puede hacerse de una forma mucho más
compleja y eso es lo que los biólogos
hacen ellos verían mucho más que cinco
rasgos vería en la evidencia molecular
con base en diferencias de proteínas con
base en diferencias de adn para
realmente comenzar a crear lo que
nosotros llamamos un árbol filogenético
déjame escribirlo
un árbol filogenético y bueno filón
viene del griego para grupo o tribu o
tipo y genético ya sabes está
relacionado a la palabra génesis
entonces puedes pensar esto con la
pregunta de cómo suceden estas cosas
cómo es que suceden los diferentes
grupos o tribus o en este caso cómo
suceden las diferentes especies bien
cuando se intenta hacer uno de estos
árboles es importante comprender que
esto es una hipótesis y como siempre
vamos a intentar tener la hipótesis más
simple que podamos para explicar lo que
observamos y cuando vemos estas especies
que tenemos listadas aquí parece que hay
una que es más diferente que todas las
demás es decir la lamprea ya que la
lamprea no tiene ninguno de estos cinco
rasgos que estamos observando así que a
esta la vamos a llamar un grupo externo
y muchas veces cuando necesitan
construir un árbol filogenético podrían
proporcionarles algo que claramente sea
un grupo externo por ejemplo aquí la
lamprea no tiene ninguno
estos rasgos visibles y si estuviéramos
viendo las diferencias genéticas están
podría tener el mayor número de
diferencias genéticas relativo claro a
todos los demás y esto tiene sentido
porque la hipótesis más simple es que su
ancestro común sea aquel que esté más
distante en el pasado que todos los
demás así que permiten empezar a dibujar
este árbol entonces voy a poner por aquí
un momento muy muy en el pasado algo más
o menos así y bueno por aquí vamos a
tener un punto de ramificación donde
vamos a tener al ancestro común de la
lamprea y todo lo demás así que
finalmente tienen este ancestro en común
y después hay muchas especies a lo largo
del camino hasta que por aquí tenemos a
la lamprea en tiempo presente entonces
la siguiente cosa que tenemos que pensar
es como todo lo demás termino
ramificándose es decir que hay en común
en todos los demás que tal vez no
tuvieron en común con la lamprea y bien
si observas una
qué tienen en común y que vemos en todos
los demás que tenemos listados aquí es
la mandíbula por lo tanto es razonable
decir que tenemos un ancestro común
entre la lamprea y todo lo demás justo
aquí y después se ramifica en múltiples
especies y una de esas especies debió de
haber evolucionado para tener mandíbulas
así que déjame escribirlo justo aquí voy
a poner mandíbulas entonces las
mandíbulas son consideradas un carácter
derivado estas especies ancestrales en
un principio no tenían mandíbulas y
estamos asumiendo que en algún punto
evolucionaron y se quedaron con las
mandíbulas ya que probaron ser
favorables en ciertos ambientes o podría
haber sido a través de un proceso como
la deriva genética quién sabe pero estoy
suponiendo que era favorable en ciertos
ambientes ahora vamos a ver si podemos
clasificar los demás las cuatro especies
que me faltan de hecho vamos a tachar a
la lamprea porque esta ya la utilizamos
y también voy a tachar mandíbulas porque
esto también ya lo
utilizamos entonces vamos al siguiente
rasgo que sea más común y si vemos el
siguiente rasgo que es más común son los
pulmones pero observa que no todas las
especies tienen pulmones el róbalo no
tiene pulmones no respira aire de la
forma en la que los animales que viven
fuera del agua respiran aire entonces el
siguiente punto de divergencia va a ser
entre el róbalo y todo lo que nos queda
así que permite dibujar eso y de nuevo
dije debe ser porque esto es una
hipótesis y bueno creo que es una
hipótesis razonable entonces por aquí
vamos a tener el róbalo déjame
escribirlo voy a tener el róbalo y hay
un ancestro común entre el róbalo y todo
lo demás justo aquí es decir entre el
róbalo y el antílope el águila calva y
el caimán y en algún punto ese ancestro
en común se dividió en múltiples
especies y una de esas especies hijas
debió de haber evolucionado a tener
pulmones en algún punto entonces aquí
voy a poner
pulmones
bien estamos suponiendo que eso no fue
en el linaje del róbalo y una vez más
solo estoy buscando la explicación más
simple también podría haber sido alguna
situación donde tal vez los pulmones
evolucionaron y luego se fueron en algún
punto para regresar a una forma más
ancestral pero prefiero tener una
explicación más simple esta explicación
más simple es una propiedad que los
biólogos llaman parsimonia déjame
escribirlo la idea de la parsimonia y
parsimonia en el lenguaje coloquial
significa simple sencillo o económico
cuando alguien les dice que son
parsimoniosos es una palabra que suena
bastante bien pero significa que eres
sencillo ahora parsimonia en este
contexto es pensar que somos simples o
que tratamos de simplificar la
complejidad estamos tratando de ser tan
simples como sea posible en nuestra
explicación de qué está ocurriendo pero
en cualquier caso volvamos a lo que
estábamos haciendo
ya hemos hablado del róbalo así que lo
voy a tachar con este color y también ya
hablamos de pulmones así que también lo
voy a quitar de aquí y ahora nos falta
hablar de plumaje pelaje y muñecas y
también del antílope el águila calva y
el caimán muy bien parece que el águila
calva y el caimán son los únicos que
tienen muñecas y el antílope tiene
pelaje de hecho aún no hemos hablado del
águila calva y sus plumas pero ahorita
vamos a hacerlo así que hagamos una rama
por aquí para hablar del águila calva y
veamos si puedo construir una que
explique las diferencias entre el águila
calva el antílope y el caimán bien el
águila calva y el caimán tienen algo en
común así que déjame poner por aquí al
caimán tanto el águila calva como el
caimán tienen muy viejas cosas que no
tiene el antílope y obviamente puede
haber puesto el caimán de este lado del
águila calva de este lado o podría haber
rotado cualquiera de estas ramas
y otro lado en cualquiera de estos dos
puntos de ramificación y después lo que
nos queda por último es el antílope así
que lo voy a escribir aquí aquí tengo al
antílope ahora veamos si puedo dar
cuenta de todos estos caracteres
derivados entonces aquí tenemos un
ancestro común entre el róbalo el águila
calva el caimán y el antílope justo aquí
tenemos este punto de ramificación y en
algún punto de esta rama evolucionaron
los pulmones entonces estamos
proponiendo una hipótesis evolucionaron
en esta rama y luego digamos que justo
aquí tenemos al ancestro común entre el
águila calva el caimán y el antílope y
un ancestro común del águila calva y del
caimán debió de tener mollejas así que
vamos a poner las muñecas con su
respectivo color justo aquí aquí tengo
las muy
y entonces todo lo que descendió de este
ancestro que tenía muy viejas tendrá
mollejas pero otra vez está muy vieja
pudo perderse es solamente una hipótesis
bien ahora vamos a tachar todo lo que
tenemos aquí para ver qué es lo que nos
falta ya contamos las mollejas así que
lo voy a quitar justo así y bueno nos
falta el plumaje el águila calva es el
único que tiene plumas así que déjame
ponerlo entonces en algún punto tenemos
un ancestro común entre el caimán y el
águila calva pero este ancestro común se
ramifica en múltiples especies una de
las cuales tiene plumas entonces déjame
ponerlo aquí y lo voy a poner con este
color tienen plumas
más bien y nuevamente eso podría haber
ramificado en muchas cosas que ya
sabemos que existen porque el águila
calva no es la única especie con plumas
pero el águila calva sin duda es una
especie que tiene plumas ok entonces
vamos a tachar también el plumaje lo voy
a quitar y por último nos falta hablar
solamente del pelaje y el único que
tiene pelaje es el antílope así que no
sabemos dónde podría haber pasado esto
podríamos querer buscar más evidencia
para llegar con una buena hipótesis pero
en algún lugar a lo largo de esta rama
derecha podríamos poner el pelaje déjame
escribirlo por aquí tenemos al pelaje
y entonces ahí lo tienes este es un
razonable árbol filogenético puse en
práctica la idea de la parsimonia para
llegar con la explicación más simple
pero hay explicaciones más complicadas y
no sabemos algunas de esas explicaciones
más complicadas podrían ser muy ciertas
pero de esto obtenemos ya una
representación gráfica y fácil de que
están relacionadas pueden estar
diferentes especies y donde comparten
ancestros comunes entonces el águila y
el caimán comparten un ancestro común
justo aquí basándonos en este árbol
filogenético y además vamos a decir que
están más relacionados que lo que está
el antílope con el caimán el águila
calva y el caimán tienen más en común o
dicho de otra manera tienen un ancestro
común más común o un ancestro común más
reciente justo ahí que el ancestro que
tienen en común el antílope y el caimán
que está hasta acá abajo y eso los haría
estar más relacionados si estuviéramos
haciendo esto más formal
entonces buscaríamos la evidencia
genética y buscaríamos distintas
proteínas es decir pensar en si el adn
del águila calva y del caimán tienen más
en común entre sí que el adn del
antílope especialmente cuando esto es
más complejo podría haber muchas
explicaciones diferentes y solo queremos
obtener más y más y más evidencias para
seguir mejorando nuestros árboles
filogenéticos